when you left football for those years
it was a it was everyone was surprised
cut off like you know
you were what like five years six years
in the league six
five five years in um and you leave
football
you know i think a lot of people the
perception was you turned into like this
hippie
guy right i did right so you turn into
this hippie guy
um you learn about aquariuses exactly
astrology
exactly uh did was there anything else
spiritual that you went through during
that time that that helped shape you
yoga yoga meditation holistic healing
like all of that
all of it came in that time in that time
period and it surprised me i didn't know
i was a hippie until i
just i ended up in this town in
australia called byron bay and i just
felt
you ended up there i just i mean so it's
kind of it's kind of funny
i mean it's kind of funny where i ended
up in australia i had this
teleported over there i had a friend i
had a friend who right after i retired
she said she was traveling to samoa
right so i was like
[ __ ] i don't have nothing to do let me
go with you and so we went to samoa and
then we went to fiji
and then she started tripping so i was
like bye and like tripping on
on hallucinations just freaking out on
youtube acting like yeah you know
anyways and so i was like you know i
don't need this
and i was like okay what am i going to
do now i'm in the middle of the pacific
you know and then i
and then i was like oh [ __ ] australia's
like really close and i want to go back
there because
i had a good time and so i flew back to
sydney hung out in sydney for a couple
of days and then i
i got this idea of this town called
byron bay that i always wanted to go to
and i never really been on a greyhound
except from san diego to el centro
and so i and in australia the greyhound
is like
everybody travels in the greyhound so i
took a greyhound from sydney to this
town in
byron bay and i thought i'd be there for
a couple of days because i wanted to
photograph a lighthouse that was there
and ended up staying there for a couple
of months and i and i learned there that
i was that i was a hippie
and then from there on i came back and
started doing hippie stuff i became a
vegetarian
started doing yoga stuff are you still
vegetarian no not anymore
you gotta eat meat man after i retired i
moved back to texas and it was
it's too hard yeah yeah with that
barbecue
some of that barbecue in texas man i had
some pork belly
that was like life changing a couple
weeks ago i was like why can't they make
it like that in california